-It's so great too,
because I imagine, like,
you grow up with Rob --
-Oh, by the way, oh, by the way,
everything's politically correct
today.
You're not supposed to say
"Sasquatch."
-No. Why?
-Yeah, no.
There's a --
The PC thing now is "wood ape."
-Why?
Who does "Sasquatch" offend?
-I have no idea,
but you can't say it.
-You have to say "wood ape"?
-You can't say "Bigfoot."
-No, you can.
-I'm not kidding.
-Really?
-This is not a bit.
This is absolutely true.
-Is this because people
with big feet are offended?
-Maybe it's that.
-Yeah.
-But I think the notion is that
the terms "Sasquatch"
and "Bigfoot" are pejorative
'cause they sound "looney."
-Oh. Oh.
-But "wood ape" is fine.
-Yeah, wood ape.
If you go out looking for
wood ape, you're a scientist.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
This is what
I'm really excited about
watching this show is you
have -- You're on Instagram.
And you've got a lot of likes.
You're at 14,000 likes.
You're obviously a popular guy
on Instagram, but your son --
John seems to be the one
that's busting you.
-He gives me a lot of --
my kids think I'm lame
on social media.
-Yeah, so here you are.
You're like,
"Thanks to my friends --
Thanks to my #friends at Tommy's
for a great #lunch."
Then, your son just wrote,
"#lunch."
[ Light laughter ]
-My sons are trolling me.
-Yeah, it's really great.
They're trolling you.
"The Grinder finally came home
and ran into Joel Zadak.
#Teenlife."
"#Teenlife??!"
[ Laughter ]
That seems like --
That seems like a fair burn
to burn you.
-Yeah, I mean...
I still -- I'm like,
"Look, guys, it could be worse.
I'm trying, you know."
-Yeah.
-I'm not this Millennial.
-You're a dad who's trying.
-I'm a dad.
-You're a dad and, look again --
you've accomplished a lot
in your life.
But there's one thing
I wanted to talk to you about
because I know that you have --
you visited the White House
a lot.
-I've been to every White House
since "The West Wing" premiered.
-Which is exciting.
-So every administration
from Clinton to Bush to Obama.
-And a very different vibe
each time?
-That's what's fascinating.
The Clinton White House was
the most welcoming, most casual.
He had, like,
his Big Bertha Golf Driver
leaning up against the wall
of the Oval Office.
-Uh-huh.
-And he'd be like, "Come on in.
Sit at the desk.
Take a picture."
And he was great. He was great.
[ Laughter ]
And the Bush White House
was really formal,
and you couldn't even go
in the Oval.
It had, like, literally,
a velvet rope,
and it was like a sanctum.
-Mm-hmm.
-You could peer in,
but you were not going in.
And Obama was like -- felt like
he was just
so much hustle and bustle.
And I think every president
brings their own kind of thing
to it.
-Now, you haven't been
to the Trump White House,
but you do have
a little bit of history.
Is it true that Donald Trump
once donated $50,000
to a charity event?
-I did. I was doing an event
for Habitat for Humanity.
-Uh-huh.
-And I was on a talk show.
He called in, and he donated,
I think, $5,000
to Habitat for Humanity.
-That's great.
-It was nice.
[ Applause ]
Yeah.
-Did you, um --
Did anybody ever see the check,
or was it
like one of those things --
[ Laughter ]
-Yes, they saw the check.
And you know what's amazing?
You know who it was signed by?
Vladimir Putin.
-No!
-It was unbelievable.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It was un--
-As long
as the houses got built.
[ Chuckling ]
As long as the houses got built.
Thanks so much for being here.
Congrats on the show.
And it's always
just such a delight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Rob Lowe, everybody!